PEGI 18 following total atomic
annihilation the rebuilding of this
great nation of ours may fall to you
that's why we at multi have prepared
these educational materials for you to
better understand seven defining
attributes that make you special our
topic today is endurance we will all be
faced with many new and unfamiliar
health risks such as infection sudden
loss of limb and above all harmful
radiation fortunately your formidable
endurance has turned your body into a
hard working machine that can resist the
harmful effects of radiation and
physical violence like any machine then
your body must be well maintained to
stay in tip-top shape while average joes
will survive on old packaged standbys
your ironclad insides will allow you to
seek fresh meat radiation poisoning may
have enlarged your favorite meals this
means more healthful nutrition for you
take caution not to bite off more than
you can chew endurance can also provide
new options for food some of which can
be an acquired taste
gone are the days of exercising for fun
instead you will need to combine
athletics with crucial survival
activities the greater your endurance
the further you can go just be certain
to be mindful of others build your
endurance and soon you will find ways
that it improves your life above ground
added confidence in the swimming pool
stronger more resilient limbs to cross
the flesh of your fellow man can travel
regularly study your vault-tec provided
materials to prepare for survival and to
answer the question do you know what
makes you special